i think there's no confusion that when
you get an owner a coach
a general manager and usually a team
captain to have that chemistry
you think about magic and riley and the
late
dr jerry buss like you get that trio
that
quad of individuals in sports uh it gets
real good real fast
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hello and welcome to another episode of
building
minnesota rocker i'm ashley aka midnight
here as
always uh with uh brett diamond the ceo
and today
he's back garyvee is back on the podcast
we've actually had you in
um i think you were down in minneapolis
that was like the beginning of this year
maybe
or late last year but obviously had a
great in
in-person podcast with you then and now
we're we're back online
and we have you on to talk about i guess
going into season two with minnesota
rocker so thanks uh for the time today
and
happy happy to have you thank you
great to be here yeah it's pretty stoked
we actually um we actually just had gary
meet uh the the new roster
for the first time which is really
exciting um
the guys are all like everyone's pretty
juiced right now because you know it's
that first like honeymoon period when
you have a brand new lineup a brand new
roster brand new vibes
but it's it's that exciting time of the
year right where the the new call of
duty is about to come out soon the new
season is starting in a few months
and then you know getting that that
touch point with you know
obviously your co-owner of the team i
don't think that touch point is there
for a lot of players so that was really
cool to see
yeah i mean look i i don't even know how
to be involved with something
and not try to bring the most value
possible and
you know obviously you got to see what
just happened but you know
i i think you know i'm less i'm more
macro than micro right
i'm going to the real [ __ ] like let's
get our
human dynamics down also because
you know if this was a sports card
company or a
wine company i i could go into the
places of craft
but with these guys you know i
i'm not even a casual cod player so what
am i going to really say to them right
like you know i'm definitely not going
to go there what i'm going to go into is
how do i bring you the most value
as the minority owner how do i you know
bring you value as a human being i don't
know i thought that went really well
obviously you
have been you know around me long enough
you two on this like that felt like a
really
great meeting that makes me feel like
excited for next year
yeah that that was really it was awesome
you you could tell the energy
that the guys were getting from the
conversation and and you could even see
it build from
you know over the course of the that you
know the the
half hour or so that you were with them
so it's it's great it's great to see it
it's exciting to see
just to feel those vibes as we head into
season two
yeah absolutely and i think we we did
record the combo so we'll probably
upload it to youtube as well so you guys
can see like that genuine just like
interaction um what what that was really
like for the guys and and for gary
um why do you think it is so important
gary for
for the players to feel connected to any
team that they're on or any organization
that they're a part of
speed i think speed wins
a lot of things and people are confused
by that and i think when you feel
connected
and you feel trust and you don't feel
politics
um then i think you know you're able to
go fast
you know like i'm saying to the guys if
you're if you like each other you're not
going to think about
dreading practice having that anxiety
and so you know i think i don't i don't
think you can
show up as your best self um in those
environments
unless you are in that place and so
you know to me continuity longevity i
mean like
i'm you know i'm sure you feel the same
way i'd be really pumped if somebody
told me
this was the core of our team for seven
eight nine seasons
right you know and so you to you want
that connection so that you build an
actual family
families win and so that's how i think
about that
yeah and that's a that's a great way to
frame it you know
and and that was true a year ago right
and we you know we loved
the guys that we had as a part of the
first roster they'll always have a
special place
of course history of this team um
you know ultimately we had to
collectively make some tough decisions
to part ways with those guys
um but the the the roster we've brought
on is truly one that we feel like can
compete for a championship and you know
hopefully this is something where you
know these are our four guys for
you know for longer than even you know
some of the you know historic
dynasty you know shorter term sometimes
in esports but some of those dynasties
that you look back at
um in the call of duty scene like that's
obviously setting you know a ridiculous
standard but you know like
that's the goal right is that you you
get this core and they and you're it's a
part of the organization
uh for a long time to come i think yeah
go ahead oh yeah just to say i think too
like when you look at building a roster
and who you want to like be the face of
your franchise it's so important to get
that player or group of players or
whatever that core
foundation is to really represent and
get people to
no pun intended attached to your team
right it's just
it's so important in in esports and i
think in traditional sports too
that personality level that's there but
it's it's so key for us here so
i'll let you go ahead too though yeah i
mean i think
i think we're all saying the same thing
i think there's no confusion that when
you get an owner a coach
a general manager and usually a team
captain to have that chemistry
you think about magic and riley and the
late
dr jerry buss like you get that trio
that quad
of individuals in sports uh it gets real
good real fast
and um you know tori and jeter and
steinbrenner like you know cash like
it's just obvious
it's obvious you know i'm not gonna use
the patriots one because it pisses me
off
but you know like it's very very very
very obvious and so
um i think that's what you know i know
for sure that's what i
and jonathan will definitely like
see he's you know he's obviously a
little bit with experience of like going
through the stuff with the vikings and
i think you know i definitely feel that
connection with you two
as we think about it and um
i i just don't think you you can once at
a blue moon win without it i believe
that to be true
occasionally you know there's athletes
that come together that are just so
spectacular and it hits right but
i couldn't even be wrong about that i
have to really look back at the
six or seven major sports in the world
last 50 years it's really hard to win it
without it being right
bet your bet
double muted especially to have that be
consistently the case
over time right exactly like nobody's
winning a back-to-back championship
without it
yeah exactly and that's the thing you
really do see you know you you
you know in any sport like you can you
know a team can have a
a great year and a great run here there
and catches fire but you see the
organizations in every sport that
have consistent success over years or
and they might have a down season here
or there and they might have to make
their own changes
um but that's you know that's hopefully
what we're building for the future here
with with all of these components
you know the ownership group yourself
the will family
ashley our coaches all of our staff that
come together
um every day to support the players and
create content for the fans and do all
the
things and you know if you find that
right mix um you know that's everybody's
goal right that's every team's goal
certainly
um you know not just ours but you know
hopefully we're hopefully we're building
the foundation for some i feel listen
i'm i'm gonna be very um
anxious uh in sports terms because
i um you know i have expectations this
year i think you know
you and ash and the rest of the team
like we've gone out and put ourselves in
a position to succeed here
yeah i think so too and that's that's
actually one of the so we have a couple
of
questions from the chat a couple
questions that we want to ask you as
well but
obviously for the team competitively
going into the second year
we we need to do better than ninth like
that's just
it's unacceptable i think by all of our
standards and so
you think yeah big time um so for the
team competitively but also for the
business yourself as an owner how are
you looking at the second season
and a chat question wants to know like
what do you think about the players who
are
quite into like building their personal
brand doing content we
seem to have a couple more content
focused guys than we did last year what
are your just thoughts going into year
two
with all those things in mind i mean the
first part you know
we got off to a really good start and i
mean let's call a spade a spade
you know the wheels came off and um it's
super disappointing
um you know i think to be very
transparent
i was just worried about the health and
well-being of my family and like because
i have so many businesses
um and i'm not the active driver of this
one like two of you
are you know it you know i
in a weird way having such a rough
season
is it was good timing because at the
time it was going down
there was some real big things in life
that you have to worry about so
that kind of softened the blow i you
know i think
coming in third or fourth this year will
hurt more of the night
last year in some weird way i can i can
already like i'm just me talking to
myself
obviously very publicly um
as far as you know i want i want every
one of my players
to be in the best position to succeed
for them
i i feel like i work for them more than
they work for me and so
i think one of the great things that
rocker offers is me
and if i'm the reason one of the kids
goes from tier b to tier a because we
interact a lot more
and and i help them get better at
content and that becomes their leverage
to leave our team in free agency
i'm being dead serious with you two
that's fine by me
because that means that the right and
this is my objective by the way
that means the rocker is the destination
a four out of eight kids
are gonna stay because they value
loyalty they're thinking 50 years down
the line we become really close it could
be a million different things
the four that don't i'm happy if they
get a monster contract
and they feel like their time here made
that happen
but when everyone sees this play out
it's also going to lead to the 500
underneath that want to come in
and so i'm excited about kids doing that
because i'm not like a traditional owner
that wants to suppress so that i can get
a better
second and third contract i don't see
the world as limited
i see it more abundant than that and uh
i also think there's a lot of incredible
talent brewing
in the teenage players in the world and
um
i hope they look at this as the
destination
yeah and you hit on something there gary
that it's interesting because it's
something that i think is foundational
to what we're doing here and that you
know
we've maybe talked in very briefly
about it um between us and you know and
john and brian and others that are part
of the
the ownership group but
it's it's that doing the right thing by
the players to make this a place that
that players want to come and
you know several of the players on this
roster took less money to come here than
they were being offered in other places
and
and that just you know that blows me
away
that that that's what's happening in
year two of this organization
and it's because of the support that we
have from you that we have
from the wealths that you know decisions
like i won't get into detail
you know but decisions that we made um
in terms of how to support
players during the pandemic you know
those are things that you know we like
to think
um we're doing those things yeah anybody
with a half a brain
and yeah the half a brain that's
listening right now is like we put our
money and our heart
where our mouth is
super complicated gary gary i've got a
question for you
so by the way leads to reputation brett
yeah absolutely
humans talk yep it's amazing that doing
the right thing
actually is the right thing from a
business defense too how about
that amazing it all it always feels that
way
yeah so so gary you talk a lot about the
ambition
of owning the new york jets someday
right
what are things that you're that you
take away from
your ownership in this team and and just
interactions that you have or things you
observe
as a part of this process how does how
those two things relate how does that
build
and does it really i think you just
watched it
you know if you don't think even for a
quick second through my mind
it ran that this talk that i'm having
right now
is going to be replicated in 27 years
with
you know 100 or 53 or 75 or whatever the
time is
guys in the national football league i
genuinely believe that to be true
which will be super fun by the way like
in this partnership one of the things
that makes me smile about this
partnership
is if i'm able to pull this off you know
it's just gonna be so amazing like the
thought of like having a
you know i basically if i could dream it
up 25 years from now i transact on the
jets
25 years from now you know version one
is a monster
gaming team in the universe so we're
partners on this but then once every you
know
four years we get to play each other in
the nfl it'll be a fun
it'll be fun late older years you know
over dinner and debate with jonathan on
that stuff so i'm looking forward to it
that's awesome i love that i've always
wondered this is it is it
jets or nothing or jets or nothing okay
yeah it's just or nothing for me i don't
i mean you never say never but i just
don't see myself
i just think i'll take those the nfl
like i just i think whatever i do at
that point in my life i'm going to
do for true enjoyment and success
and i just don't know i mean to me
really the consolation prize is the mix
and after that it becomes something
completely
it's like what's the point i don't i'm
out i think yeah i mean
i think it's kind of it's cool that
that's kind of like the catalyst for for
you wanting to do this obviously you
understand the value that that esports
brings i mean you have vayner gaming
i would have been i would have i would
have been more passive to your point
actually you know
i would have i would have and will
continue to invest in the ecosystem
but what probably pushed me hard to team
ownership in this environment
no question is the macro and the
relationship with the wealth i've known
them since i was a kid
you know they grew up in the part of new
jersey that i grew up
working at and you know um and so
there's a real warm feeling there's real
warmth there
yeah the feeling i get especially from
someone who's been working in esports
for 10 years and seeing this investment
money come and seeing these vcs come in
and just
try to be like oh yeah i want to do this
with the will family it genuinely feels
like they're here to
do it the right way and do like like
execute fully on it like they're just
not here for novelty
oh we have a gaming team too like oh
this is
the furthest thing from vanity or or
throwaway or let's learn i mean this is
they're in it
yeah i'm sure you see it um big
time i mean brett obviously worked with
them in in the nfl organization like
you know i mean i think john you know
jonathan's deeper in it than i am in it
like they're in it
yeah and that's that's something that
i've like really come to respect over
this like last year that i've i've been
working with the team
is just that they're gonna they want to
operate and do the right things we're
growing and
fulfilling some of the goals that we've
set out in front of us in just year one
um but now it's you know it it just
feels
all the more better when you have a
strong foundation who's in it with you
and not just like oh yeah
like here's a budget have fun
and i think it hit on ashley that's one
of the common threads that i think ties
a lot of these pieces together right you
know that mindset of okay we're
you know we're not coming into this
scene acting like we have all the
answers because of success
in traditional sports or in other areas
of business it's that mentality of
wanting to and genuinely enjoying you
know gary you talk so much about the
process right i'm a big believer in that
genuinely enjoying this process of
learning about the scene
you're getting to know the fans and as
we enter any additional title what that
looks like and i think that's true
of john and his family you know gary
from everything you said i know that's
true about you and that's one of the
things that attracted me
to this opportunity and frankly i would
not have jumped on board
with you know with an ownership group
that i didn't think had that i know
that's true you actually
know a lot of our staff as well like it
ties a lot of what we're about together
yeah it definitely does i mean like i
said i've seen ownership come in
and directly mess it up with with just
trying to throw money at it and hope
that
that they do the thing um it's it's
always about that
that just the continuity between the top
down like what are we trying to do here
what can we execute on and how can we do
it um so kind of speaking like in that
same vein
gary when you were building vaynermedia
what was the transition like from year
one to two was it
black and white was it just a gradual
fade up
so it's it's a great question given the
context of this show and where we're at
it's funny the first you know 18 months
i was
i was very passive with vaynermedia by
comparison because i was still really
running wine library
and i wanted to give aj room to do his
thing like
you know get all that pent up you know
energy from
being in school for seven years probably
longer than he wanted to be and i wanted
to see what he was about i wanted him to
learn
i also wrote crush it
um and it went completely viral and
you know had my first child so it was a
very like the first
18 months i was pretty passive then i
got involved
and and then it really lifted off
um so i think ironically you're three
and four
is more of the comp here and you know i
think it becomes
it's why we just had such good free
agency
you know what what happened there what's
happening here it's like
you come in with all the right
ingredients we've been talking about
ingredients
mindset the relationships the intent
the talent that we have at ownership and
i and
and then more importantly thank god for
you too like senior leadership
right then you start learning
learning is everything so it's like it's
almost like you have the best garden
in the world with the best pond with the
best fish and the greatest
chicken coop but you might actually just
be
okay or solid you have all the talent
you're you're destined to be one of the
great chefs of all time
but you need to go through the reps so
for me that's what year two is like like
when we were going through a free agency
and obviously you two were more active
than i was but when
you know like communication looking at
thoughts like i just i can feel my
chemicals right now so i remember the
feeling i was like wow
we are we are really on our way like i
am one of the less deep in i know all of
these guys
like you know you know what i mean like
i'm like okay we're in this
you know and and we were successful in
getting you know i mean you know to give
credit to you
ashley and i felt like we went after a
lot of
great people in year one two got some
didn't get everyone you know
so being able to execute you know this
is where ingredients matter
by what we did during covet who we
actually are as human beings
nice honor all that reputation
winning some of the free agency
sweepstakes because of it let's call a
spade a spade
um that's the transition you know more
yeah which makes you better i think
that's most definitely true and and
i got to give credit to where all
credits do like obviously brett and i
were a huge part of building that first
initial roster
going into year two we wanted to leave
it almost entirely up to the coaching
staff in brian saint
and and jake who's the assistant coach
and lead analyst
they put in so much work during this off
season to make this happen
but i think the biggest thing that i
noticed when i did come into some
because i did
eventually come into some conversations
and start trying to be like hey
like content like let's help you grow
um you know coming into that like last
year for example
we were on the phone with priesta brett9
we're like
he was our number one like we want this
guy and
he ended up going to phase but i could
totally understand they're very built
out they have
their great infrastructure great team um
and we just
we were saying a bunch of things that we
wanted to do but how can they believe it
we just got here right and so but after
year one
they saw oh launch event weekend was a
sick event like the
the armory looked amazing that the
players were all treated well even if
they weren't on our team shout out to
that
um and just like making sure that that
reputation starts to get built and it's
because we have the ingredients here
in the senior staff all the way like
down to any interns we hire like we
literally are all on the same page of
this
and it is the ingredient factor it's the
solid support from ownership
and the direction that they give versus
how we execute it
yep cosine nailed it
exactly i mean that was statement form
and so
what i want to do in those moments is
not answer when nothing's needed that is
a big fat yes
yes i'm into it um so about vayner
gaming i noticed um you guys have really
like
doubled down on that like i love that
like you're you're you're assigning more
gamers you're
you're being more involved with like
twitch streaming and stuff like that
talk about like what you want to do in
that space and kind of what vayner
gaming is
so it's interesting right i'm very
active in gaming but i'm one b
or two in both places right i i just am
i'm one b or two however you want to
define it on
version one in a world where i'm one a
in a lot of the things i do there's a
lot of places i'm one b or two and then
there's things
the majority things i'm passive i'm an
investor i'm an advisor
i'm not active um so you know i'm one b
two in both arenas but you know
obviously
you know reed birdman who works in
the vayner world brings you know kyle to
our offices we build a long-term
relationship there
able to establish vayner gaming with one
of the most prolific players i mean
i truly believe kyle is going to be an
all-time great
gamer because of his skill sets just
translate to so many other things
um you know i i'm staying away from cod
players
because i need to really like get
educated both from my lawyers like i
haven't gone there yet so i haven't
really gotten it like that that seems
very off-limits to me and
rocket league i'm gonna have to really
figure out what's gonna happen
as these two screens brew as version one
starts to expand quite a bit
um so still leaves an incredible amount
of things
unlimited amount of players for
representation in other things outside
of things we do with version one
um so just genuinely excited about it i
think we're gonna bring a ton of value
we've
we've made kyle a lot of money off
appealing endorsements and marketing and
content and
we plan on doing that and just like
being an owner you know
when you're a manager an agent you want
to help people you want to get the most
for them you want to be their older
brother and dad
and you know and whatever they want you
to be and
um it's clearly a sp listen esports is
going to be a space that i'm going to be
in
for the rest of my life um and i'm
excited about that
i believe that um that uh
gaming and esports is a top four
sport globally with soccer basketball
and
mixed martial arts in 25 years
and that's good because i'll still be a
young man and hopefully all those
successes in
these things and others will allow me to
buy a very american sports team
that i enjoy i love that
uh so over the course of the past few
months you've launched a lot of new
initiatives right we just talked about
vayner gaming that's one you
vaynercommerce and then just from the
content standpoint
t with gary vee marketing for the now
i'm curious
one of those things obviously some
clearly took runway to get to a point
where you can launch them
but i've wondered of those things
with the onset of the pandemic how did
that factor into the decision-making of
dewey lines marketing for the now
marketing for the now in t with garyvee
zero conversation prior to pandemic
turned during pandemic uh
gaming was brewing but maybe the focus
time
allowed that to happen but that was
brewing uh
vayner commerce was very in play
it actually existed the announcement
schedule was affected moved it up a
little bit
because to take advantage of everybody
caring about commerce
the empathying transaction that i sold
to consolation which is a huge
transaction in my career that started in
october
ironically closed verbally the first day
i was home
like kind of not in the office um
i was trying to think of it you know
yeah i've definitely been very active
um i think i mean there's i mean
right now really what's been happening
with me the last six months i was just
saying
it to lou and alexandra my admins like
my allocation
of time to vayner x is extraordinary
you know vaynermedia the gallery media
group which is purewow.com at 1 37 p.m
which
we do a lot of content in this space um
tracer
and you know the sasha group so i have a
bunch of b
pro i have a bunch of companies um
vayner speakers
in this holding marketing comms company
i've been really focused there because
that is the core business and you know
obviously navigating through
a global pandemic is we got offices in
singapore and london so i've had a lot
on my plate
but but there are there are multiple
things i'm always
working on 64th you know
juggling 64 things and 29 fall to the
ground and break and
six get thrown up all the way and become
real and that that's where i sit
i sit in this place in the middle where
ideas
either die or get created
and then i sit up there operating those
and some of those lose and some of them
win and that's my life
that's interesting that's something i've
always throughout my career tried to
observe of when i was
you know in a more junior position
executives around me are executives that
i had the opportunity to work
for with you know what that balance of
time spent between
sort of like what's directly in front of
you or what's sort of like managing the
crisis of the moment
versus the higher level strategic
thinking and it's super important to us
i mean something our leadership team
with this organization is talking a lot
about as we think about the evolution
entering year two and now our staff is
20 people and not three and you know
it's just
what we we're growing companies so we
have to we have to define a lot of those
things
yep i mean it is everything you know
the gray and the black and white right
the gray that we've talked a lot about
the humanity the kindness the empathy
the passion the compassion
all those things and then the black and
white like operations right
you know and um you know i think i think
a lot about wartime generals versus
peacetime generals
you know i think the thing that you
probably observed was when the heat is
on
i'm sure you saw executives that you
were close to right in your career that
cracked
and would yell at people and make people
feel like [ __ ] and all those things and
you have other people that would lift
people up and that's the difference
between leaders and bosses and
i think about that every day yeah that's
interesting yeah
right after launch weekend annie andy
scott riley are ahead of marketing
and i had a conversation about how we
had been wartime generals to just like
to get through that first event that was
such a heavy lift and
everything to get off the ground and at
some point we need to
sort of pivot to being peacetime
generals and then a
pandemic hit and you know sort of back
to back to the wartime general live but
um how are we doing on on one minute we
got one minute all right
all right i'm gonna quickly hit you with
a couple quick hits um
when are you 1v1 in hector and what do
you want to love you want him on i know
you guys were meant to play some pickup
basketball then the pandemic hit
you trying to play him on cod basketball
foosball what's that nhl game
you rock yeah yeah nhl 94 i'll destroy
hector
madden 94 i'll destroy hector ice hockey
for nintendo i'll destroy hector
you know anything that starts getting
into xbox and playstation
actually playstation one i i did some
real
damage battle arena and all those things
um
yeah i'm trying to stay away from
anything that's happened since i've
started working for a living which is
1998.
you know anything 1998 on i'm very
scared of hector anything 1998 pre
um i'm very focused i think we could
meet in the middle we'll find something
for you guys to meet in the middle the
next time you guys are both at an event
um gary i don't i don't have much to add
i know i know your time's precious i
really appreciate you coming on with us
today um i know we're going to have
attach on tea with gary vee on october
13th i believe and that's at nine
eastern right
that's correct and that's on your your
channels ever i mean all my live
channels will attach will be on i think
somebody else is joining so
i'm not the best with logistics so this
is the one thing i can't answer on the
spot but
really looking forward to it um and i
think press them actually yeah i think
it's going to be present attached
separately so yep
got it and uh i love you guys we'll talk
soon
bye everyone who's watching thank you so
much gary
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out